it's day three of 100 days of cheese and
we're making fried mac and cheese balls
covered in Doritos if you have a lot of
frustrations you can whack a bag of
chips like me or just put these through
a food processor then mix together some
cheddar mozzarella and of course store
bought or leftover mac and cheese and a
tiny bit of flour scoop those out or you
can roll into a ball with your hand make
sure to chill those for about 20 minutes
before you toss that in some flour eggs
and that Dorito goodness put these in a
little fry bath once they're done make
sure to season with a little salt you
can add some chives or green onion these
definitely have an EG plus cheese Bowl
but how do they taste smells like
Doritos this is a five out of five I'm
in love